this is a great happiness for me that  the Academy is showing this wonderful  film which is made me made me become an  actor made me become somebody known  Lawrence of Arabia Lawrence of Arabia  was a tremendous film thank David Lean  for what he did for me for all the  cinema people because I think it is one  of the best films in the ten greatest  films in the world and I it did me a lot  of good I was nobody I was an Egyptian  actor doing nothing and with David Lean  I became an important celebrity I hate  to say that but that is what happened  I'm very happy I never forget this  extraordinary thing that happened to me  Lawrence of Arabia thank you very much  enjoy